for the first time lawmakers will hear
from one of president Trump's most
trusted former aides following the
release of the Muller report former
White House communications director hope
Hicks meets with the House Judiciary
Committee today behind closed doors
after the White House tried to block it
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
what a committee members plan to ask her
they're going to ask her Anthony about a
series of episodes that are detailed in
the Muller report in which she is listed
quite frequently she was one of the
president's closest advisors when she
was in the White House and during the
campaign this is the committee that is
looking into whether the president
obstructed justice by trying to
interfere with the Muller investigation
something the president has always
denied one democratic aide telling CBS
News that the committee is going to ask
Hicks about the firing of FBI director
James Comey and that infamous meeting
between the president's son and a
Russian lawyer at Trump Tower in 2016
she's also expected to be questioned
about hush money payments that president
Trump's former personal attorney Michael
Cohen made to adult film actress stormy
Daniels now what's not clear to us is
how many questions Hicks is actually
going to answer today on Tuesday the
White House's top lawyer sent a letter
to committee chairman Jerry Nadler
saying that Hicks quote is absolutely
immune from compelled testimony
concerning her service to the president
Democrats disagree they say that the
White House cannot exert executive
privilege Tony over material that Hicks
has already handed over to the special
counsel Nancy Cordes for us Nancy thank
you very much